every time you move up
there is a next level you may be the
best player at
ymca league tuesday thursday saturday
league you crush everybody
you're you're the rocks and when you
leave people are taking pictures with
you oh that's me on tuesday and then
and then you go play out in la fitness
league
8 a.m in the morning 7 8 in the morning
you're a nobody
but let's just say you eventually get so
competitive that you play good at the la
fitness plays
then you go play against college
basketball players
and then you're nobody then let's just
say you get good enough to play for
college
then all of a sudden you have what it
takes to go into the nba you're actually
doing something you went into the final
four you made a name for yourself
you go into the nba then all of a sudden
you're like dude it's a freaking
different game these guys
are so much quicker next level then you
get good enough to be an all-star
now you're going to the all-star game
then you're good enough to go into the
playoffs
then you go into the finals then you see
the other guy handles pressure better
than you do
he's a champion you were a 14-year nba
veteran but the guy won a championship
you didn't
there's always the next level at every
level
and the next level at every level is
more demanding and there are people that
eventually say
i'm just not gonna go at this level i'm
just not
i'm just not gonna go at this level by
the way and i'm fully convinced
gerard this mindset
is applicable to every industry
i am convinced in hollywood the guys who
eventually become the stephen spielbergs
of the world
while everybody else is going out there
celebrating hardcore partying i'm well
i'm convinced those guys go out there
and they're working on their next script
i'm convinced those guys go out there
and they're already looking at the next
thing almost
every single person i've studied who
made it at the highest level
you know the similar answer is like
what's your favorite movie ever made
you know what they say i haven't made it
yet the next one yeah what's your
favorite championship
the next the point is it's like
my favorite ring is the one that i
haven't gotten versus the people always
like well let me tell you man back in
you know
1993 when i did xyz that's the problem
al bundy scored four touchdowns repo
that's the problem so if you were there
in the world of competition
yes you want to get by the way just so
everybody knows so everybody knows this
dei you know uh
uh uh diverse uh equity and inclusive
the person who said these words just so
let me
read it the person who said these words
her name not his name her name is mary
callahan erdos the ceo of jp morgan
chase assen and wealth management
division
her name so this is not if it's a he or
a she
she says to make it requires 12 hours a
day six days a week
to make it at two and a half years she
says that this is not like
a bunch of men that are making other men
work hard and all this other stuff
no by the way i've sat with women in the
financial industry
let me tell you some of the most
impressive people i've ever sat across
beasts beasts you sit there that will
eat your lunch
and they're intimidating they're so
solid because they can compete in this
league
men fear these women so it's not about
this isn't about sex this isn't about
color this isn't about any
this is about are you willing to pay the
price to be the cream of the crop
in your industry how bad do you want it
are you willing to meet the demand and
i'm telling you gerard
i'm telling you 99
of the time you can eventually hit a
level that you can either say i'm
content with this amount of uh
you know what we produce with a product
and in that moment there's a breaking
point to say
you're going to go a little bit more
because the other guy's going to go a
little bit more you're going to go a
little bit more like you know
you do this thing you do this
visualization that's the one always the
next level you're always at the bottom
of the next level everybody's always at
the bottom of the next level
all of us well you basically had this
conversation with shaq right i mean
more or less so with kobe but shaq
doesn't want to have this conversation
but the whole idea
when he said how great would would shaq
be if you had your work
ethic be the best player of all jack
said it's the dumbest question anyone's
ever asked and he dm
he was pissed off and he blocked me so
jack come on the podcast let's let's
work this thing out all right
the guy again though multiple time
champion hall of famer business icon
you know there's i guess okay i don't
disagree with anything you've said
i disagree with nothing that you've said
but just to give
i don't know another opinion all right
i've seen guys that do want it too bad
and they it's all they think about and
they obsess about it and then and they
go
uh i i i was one of those guys
especially it's all you think about it's
everything and then when when the wheel
breaks a little bit it breaks all the
way
like when when there's a little crack it
cracks all the way
i think that there has to be some sort
of to me it's like a ferrari right you
can take the best car
in the world and if you keep it in the
red
the whole time and you push push push
push push it
the best car in the world is going to be
no one's ever said that no one's ever
said that by the way
that is a misconception right there
gerard so let me let me take you back
when you hear stories like that of a
person that gave everything and they
still didn't make it
it is such a discouraging story for
young kids that are sitting there saying
effort why am i going to give my best
it's a very discouraging story let me
let me explain
is worth it no okay for sure now it's a
different story but but let me give you
the other side
we will rarely talk about our f ups on
why we didn't make it to the next level
we will rarely talk about our f ups why
we didn't make it to the next level
rarely one day mario is talking to me
and i love watching mario play soccer i
mean it's just
if mario plays i want to watch this guy
you guys got cavs for days not just
casper days i just like
watching him play you know what he said
to me the other day he said you know
what my one of my biggest fears in life
is he says one of my biggest fears in
life is the fact that i can't ever play
soccer again can you imagine this guy
says one of my biggest fears in life is
that i can't play the game i love
playing okay this is him so he tells a
story he says one time i'm a junior or
whatever i mean sophomore
what is tenth grade whatever tim it says
freshman or freshman is night right
okay sophomores so he says i'm a
sophomore right now and i'm playing for
the varsity team and he's kicking us
he's doing a great i think he's the
captain of the team whatever
and there's this moment where the coach
is challenging him and he talks back
and he just publicly you know goes after
his uh what do you call it his coach
and the coach pulls him aside and he
says you know what you just messed up
everything
you're off the team you're gonna play
you're never gonna get playing time with
me
okay and he says i'm like i quit i give
up and he left
so then you hear that story and you say
okay
that's probably not a story you want to
tell publicly but mario's told that
story publicly right here's what i did
those stories we all have i have those
stories where i was at when i'm coming
up i'm a six four and a half guy what do
you mean you didn't play any kind of
organized sports i have my own stories
what i didn't want to do everybody has
those stories but sometimes when you're
saying a guy doesn't make it today he
gave everything he did this he did that
sometimes one to me is you just don't
have the talent to play at that level
that's number one which is true which is
very true max out first of all you
played semi-pro baseball what are you
talking about like
what percentage of the freaking kids out
of high school ever play college later
on semi or maybe you could
hit the [ __ ] out of a fast
the other day tell me tom's like hey i
took gerard to baseball game this is
tom's uh uh
you know commentary on taking gerard to
baseball and he says i take the gerard
to a baseball game
and which was awesome thank you yeah he
said we go to a baseball game it's a
pitching dude which he loves and he says
we go to a place and the guy is throwing
pitches and
they're allowing people to hit so gerard
goes in and he grabs a bat he says
uh you're going to let me use this metal
band and the guy says yeah you sure
yeah okay nobody knows who he is they're
just kind of like another guy that's
coming here trying to hit our baseball
so the guy starts pitching tom's like
pat
gerard look like an mlb player everybody
was
shell-shocked with how beautiful gerard
was hitting the ball
on the field or this isn't the batting
cage yeah he says
he was killing it people like who is
this guy
meaning it's a white cecil fielder
white cecil fielder what's the most home
runs you ever hit in a season 47
51 i don't know yeah 51. so anyway i
could see you being a cecil fielder
so but the point is there's a little bit
of talent junior there's a little bit of
talent there's a little bit of attitude
there's a little bit of ego there's a
little bit of you're not coachable
there's a little bit of nobody tells me
what to do there's a little bit of your
primadonna of who you were in the high
school because
sometimes when a kid knows from 10th
grade he's going to be an mlb that's
actually a bad thing
yeah like you know the kid that knows
like this guy's going to be an mlb
somebody needs to say around when he was
going on the nba well just you you shot
you're right you just shut off the other
way bro
don't listen you're like dude i know
what are you talking about you're just a
60 000
year teacher what do you know i'm going
to be a freaking multi-million dollar
contractor you have that
absolute arrogant no one wants to coach
you
no one's my guy's in the company right
now we have we we've had a lot of
different people in the company right
the the number one earner is not the
most talented guy in the company and
they say it
they say it one of the best things i've
i've ever heard in a history basketball
was they asked who's the guy that came
up with uh triangle offense is it text
winner
yeah yeah text winner who taught phil
jackson about the triangle so they
interviewed your text winner they say
text
you've been this league for a long time
since a long time long time 50 years yes
a long time
who did you coach
that knew the most about basketball he
says oh that's easy he said who said
jordan farmer
it's a jordan point guard by jordan
he says why jordan farmer he says
because you couldn't teach the guy
anything
he knew it all oh man
think about that analogy jordan
if you're listening to sales this is
techs
and by the way i like this game when he
was on the lakers yeah i like this game
and when i played in china or europe i
don't know where he played
and he came back and he actually
recovered he ended up having the talent
of his career was good
so i think there's more to the story
than just okay so let me ask this
okay how do you reconcile those two
things and then come back and find that
next gear
if you feel like you've gotten as far as
you can go i
put the work done i've done as much as i
can and i've done the best i can
how do you then find that next gear in
another career or in that specific sport
you're still in or business
well what do you think should you should
you leave and create something else
here's here's what i tell you what what
i would do
is number one like for me you know in
july of 2009 i said we're gonna have a
half a million
half a million licensed agents by 2029
that's a pretty crazy vision too
cast at that time we had like 66 agents
when we started the company in september
of 09.
and i said we're going to have a half a
million licensed agents crazy 29 30
years old fine
insane but why did i say it at first
when i got into sales and working at
valleys
i'm saying i'm like dude i suck at sales
gerard i was the worst sales person i'm
the best guy best in shape guy at the
gym i couldn't sell one membership
it can't be worse than the guy at la
fitness it cannot be
four weeks goes by eight week i go to
cisco i say cisco i'm gonna go back into
the army i
suck he said what do you mean i suck he
said before you quit
just give it one more month i said i
said you have to realize i'm the worst
salesman in here
he says go and sell memberships at the
mall i said let me get this straight i
can't sell memberships at a gym with
equipment here you want to go sell
memberships at a mall because i want you
to go to fox hills mall just go to fox
home so i'll go to fox's mall
and i'm behind the desk you know
escalators behind me
people are walking i would not leave
here but the best guys were always there
i was always in the back
okay so i noticed this guy so i'm like
screw it i'm going to go to the front i
go to the front i sell my first
membership got girl comes never forget
this girl nicest girl
75 dollars and 32 a month corporate
contract i'm like i sold the contract
i sold the member i'm not going back to
the army i was so excited this 21 year
old camera finally sold the damn
membership right
so september of 2019 99 what i'm 20
years old right
30 days goes by i break the record i
become the rookie the month and then i
come back and i become a manager anyways
things start taking off for me then i
get into the insurance space it was
it was confidence is what you need
confidence came back up then i'm like
but i'm still partying i'm so distracted
i'm still all this other stuff then i go
into the insurance i'm like
this is getting hard i don't think this
is for me so you get past that face then
everybody's then you start making money
then start winning then everybody starts
telling you how amazing you are
you're freaking ridiculous bro
one of the greatest drugs one of the
greatest drugs that's not even a drug is
flattery
flattery ruins uh women men and
athletes and business people you're so
amazing you're better than your dad
you're better than this you're better
than like that kind of stuff when people
say
yeah this division is like dude you know
so you become that cocky so the words
i got lucky where people said other
things to me
behind closed doors okay i got lucky
they would say the opposite it's like
well we'll see a lot of guys have come
and they've collapsed
a lot of guys have come and they've
ruined their careers because of that
that that a lot of guys have come up
like you and they've done this
that's what i needed i feared losing it
all and i heard that messaging so now
you get to a person that says okay
i get to point i don't make it what do i
do at a level like that number one
i would get serious counsel like the
fighter
mickey tells dickie ma stop acting like
vicky's gonna fight again he's 40 years
old
stop lying to him he's never going to
fight again
our truth hard truth from people that
love you that you know they're not
going to lie to you it's not easy to do
it's got to be behind closed doors you
and them
then based on that you can't rely on one
it's got to be three or four because
they've got to give you a different
perspective
and then at that point you got to make
that decision and move on in your gut if
you get a feeling that this is what it
is now
here's the other part some people will
hear this message they will only go talk
to the people
that they know they're going to tell
them to move on i had a guy that told me
right for a way out looking for a way
out one of the guys i'm uh consulting
the stanfield they have a pizza shop
love these guys they
call me and they say um hey pat yes
uh we have made a decision we're moving
on from the pizza business we're gonna
go into a different industry
i said really so yeah were you on it or
no did you hear my conversation with
them
i said really you're moving on say yes
tell me why oh we just know we're going
to do better in different businesses
so okay interesting i said let me ask
you a question uh
is it because you think you're going to
do different things in bed in a
different industry or do you think this
thing got really really hard and you
just kind of want to throw in the towel
well no i think it's because we want to
move to a different industry
i said can i ask you guys a question
here so you pay a lot of money to me on
a monthly basis why are you bullshitting
me
what's the point of you bullshitting me
like you're paying me like what are you
trying to impress me
don't don't try to impress me just tell
me what do you guys talk about late at
night in bed
how much do you hate your current
business because of how hard it is
and they look at each other and he says
just tell him just tell him
and she says pat covett was hard selling
pizza during cover it was hard it's the
hardest thing we ever did
i said what happened to you guys telling
me nine months ago you guys want to
build a franchise doing 30 million
a year and all of a sudden you're
discouraged nine months later what
happened here
i said here's how i work when it comes
down to marriage you guys want to get a
divorce i said i
believe in divorce i'm not one that says
you know what is it called the uh uh uh
you know anyways this stuff you know
that does part all of a sudden i do
think sometimes marriage does make sense
my parents got a divorce best decision
they made to get in a divorce
before you get a divorce 12 therapy
sessions
together with a therapist six by
yourself
if after that you guys are still
convinced you guys got to go out there
and throw in the towel guess what
go get the divorce and you gave it a
shot that's what i'm saying
that's what i'm saying so meaning before
you say oh it's not going to work yet
i'm going to go to the next business
because the guy asked me a question this
last week
i say what do you say to the insurance
agent that's struggling he's been having
a hard time last two years
i said listen you're either struggling
because you're not working
you're either struggling because your
attitude sucks you're either struggling
because you're not getting better
because the language
or you're struggling because you're just
newer in the business
and you haven't hit the five year marker
stick around five years
five years later give your best if
you're not making the kind of money you
want and the lifestyle you have
then consider moving on but if you do it
after 18 more months what do you know
about this industry you know nothing yet
so
there's a combination it's such there is
no black and white answer to it i've
seen some people that have such a big
upside
go talk to somebody that they know
they're going to say oh baby this is too
much work for you
go home you should take a break this is
too stressful that guy all he cares
about is money
and they ruined the guy's life and now
he's broke still living with mommy and
daddy
so it's very important who you go into
and talk to when you're all the way at
the
decision-making point relationship or
career i've heard you use uh
tell this story before and you talked
about who's in your ear and what they're
saying and
uh flattery and all that you've said
something to the effect of
when your top guys are killing it that's
when you kind of bring them back down to
earth
or when someone's struggling that's when
you kind of build them up you've said
this before right like
if someone's killing it they had their
best six months of their life or
whatever
you don't be like bro you're the killer
you're the man you say hey
so tell us about that yeah it's a
mistake when a guy's killing it you
don't over build them up
because you know the one thing goes when
you win and you make money
or you're winning in sports business
life in anything
the moment you start winning paranoia
goes away yeah
once you start believing the hype
drinking your own yeah
it is so it's a motivating factor it is
so dangerous when paranoia goes away hey
man you just won
literally last night i
but we talked about this before and this
brings this whole thing full
circle man was i played with a lot of
dudes and i see
it's crazy because i see it now as like
a second wave of my life
i see it now with dudes that have been
in creative industry and the guys that
have been in their life
i think people you talked about partying
and losing focus i i think some people
seek that out
on purpose because it's easier for me to
say
i didn't make it because i started
drinking or i didn't make it because oh
man i got i got into the girls
yeah it's way easier to say if only i
hadn't drank
then dude i just wasn't gonna if i
didn't have that ankle injury
everyone wants an excuse no one wants to
say yeah i did it and i just woke up but
you seek it out just in case like simone
biles like
i don't know anything about simone biles
from a wall but she's a champion
maybe she thought man i just don't have
it this time anxiety or covid or
something
this this we it's better for me to back
out with an excuse than it is for me to
not win gold i can't see me as anything
other than a champion
why you know what's so crazy i don't
know if that's true it was a crazy thing
we will never know
because there's certain things in life
we will never tell the truth to the
world
to save face you will there are certain
questions
you will never ever know
the answer to that question never there
are a lot of decisions that we make
and we're very good at acting as if we
made the right decision to protect our
egos and protect our
position we're pros at it every one of
us in the world is pro at this
this isn't like you're better than
another person than another person
and every once in a while if you can
show the humane side that i effed up and
i wish i would have done something
differently
then people realize you're human and
they'd relate to you we all want to be
able to do that but it's so hard
vulnerability is really hard so hard to
do so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch or if you want to see the entire
podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye